je ne pense jamais à ça je ne pense pas
que je suis un symbole pour les gens
pour moi c'est une vaste rigolade je ne
prends pas du tout ça au sérieux je ne
peux pas prendre ça au sérieux alors ça
sera le début de la fin
on est jeune on se sent perdu dans le
monde alors on se retrouve entre Squad
dans les cafés on joue bien électrique
on écoute les yéyé sur le jukebox on
essaie de passer sa jeunesse et de
s'oublier un peu soi-même en
s'assimilant à des vedettes qu'on aime
Claude ou Sylvie Johnny ou Françoise
nous avons suivi Françoise Hardy le
symbole d'une certaine jeunesse mais
voici d'abord une de ses admiratrices
elle s'appelle Christiane elle a fondé
un club des admirateurs de Françoise
autant la beauté physique que la beauté
spirituelle le symbole de
de l'amitié de de la beauté de la beauté
intérieure
lorsqu'elle chante ces chansons sont
elles sont très fraîches elles sont
comme on dirait qu'elle sorte d'un nuage
Savoie frère
mais très sûr en même temps
ça m'emporte donc dans un autre monde je
ne suis plus sur par exemple à Paris je
ne suis plus dans ma chambre je suis
enfrançoise après s'arrête de chanter
l'électrophone s'arrête et bien c'est
très cruel ça de retomber dans dans la
vie réelle
[Musique]
mais je ne pense jamais à ça je ne pense
pas que je suis un symbole pour les gens
pour moi c'est une vaste rigolade je ne
prends pas du tout ça au sérieux je ne
peux pas prendre ça au sérieux alors ça
sera le début de la fin quand je l'ai en
face de moi quand j'ai cette
réalité cette sorte de réalité en face
de moi dans la personne d'une
admiratrice si vous voulez ou d'une
fille qui est comme ça devant moi alors
ça m'est tellement déplaisant et je ne
peux tellement pas soutenir ça que je
m'en vais je fiche le camp je déteste
voir voir les les filles qui qui
semblent éprouver pour moi comme une
espèce d'admiration ou d'adoration je ne
sais pas parce que ça me
je sais pas ça me trouble puis je veux
pas le voir c'est ce qui mérite dans
cette situation c'est d'être obligé de
correspondre à une image et je déteste
cet objet de faire ou d'être quoi que ce
soit
on y va
voilà c'est ça oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la séance du photographe comme il a fait
ça tu es formidable
[Applaudissements]
quand vous vous regardez le matin dans
la glace qu'est-ce que vous dites de
vous comment vous imaginez à l'intérieur
comment vous êtes à l'intérieur de votre
tête quand je me vois dans la glace je
vois à l'extérieur je vois pas
l'intérieur comment vous voulez imaginez
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi parce que ça me fait peur ce
qui me fait peur j'ai vite pourquoi ça
vous fait peur
parce que c'était
parce
que j'ai peur de du vide que je risque
d'y trouver je passe ma vie entre deux
avions ou entre deux séances de
photographie à courir toute la journée
et puis une fois arrivé là où je dois ou
là où je suis censée être attendre que
ça se passe
ça c'était à dire les répétitions les
galas ou bien les photos les interviews
tout ça n'est pas très important en soi
mais ça
dévore tout le temps
[Musique]
une fille chante la
l'amour qui passe souvent
et sirènes qui nous charme
et mets nos coeurs à l'envers
François Françoise Hardy
on peut y aller
qu'est-ce qui s'occupe des micro là
[Applaudissements]
le maximum
de graves et les cours
de la limite
dans les copains
[Musique]
c'est le temps de l'amour le temps des
copains et de l'aventure
quand le temps va et vient on ne pense à
rien malgré ces
blessures calmes tant de l'amour c'est
long et ses cours ça dure toujours
on s'en souvient
[Musique]
on se dit qu'avant on est le groupe
alors qu'est-ce que vous faites on reste
pas tout quoi bon ben alors
ok
[Musique]
on recommence tout
nombre est pleine de lumière
et le bouchon de tes nouvelles
je te fais de tes crinière
tu verras si je t'aimerai
sur le bois de notre grand lit
avec mes ongles j'écrirai
de mon grand comme des pays
tu verras si je t'aimerai
et puis j'arracherai les voiles même des
bateaux qui t'emporterai
et puis j'arracherai les ailes des
oiseaux je te garderai
on est pas du tout les violons de si on
s'entend comme ça ce soir ça sera
merveille car la vie suit son cours et
l'eau n'est toute heureuse d'être
amoureux
de la Lune
et de l'aventure
quand le temps va aller viens on ne
pensait rien malgré ses blessures
car le temps de l'amour c'est long
et c'est à dire toujours
souviens
on s'en souvient
merci beaucoup j'espère que tu vas bien
Jean-Jacques
je pars de chanteurs que les gens un peu
difficile
j'écris des chansons parce que je
voulais dire mille fois parce que
j'adore les chansons et
d'être capable enfin de pouvoir en faire
de temps en temps c'est ma plus grande
satisfaction professionnelle parce que
c'est la seule chose que je sois capable
de faire vraiment
[Musique]